في تداعيات الانسانيه للاشتباكات الجاريه
اعلن برنامج الغذاء العالمي التابع للامم
المتحده تعليقا وقتا لعمليته في السودان
بعد مقتل ثلاثه من موظفي خلال اشتباكات
مسلحه وقعت امس في شمال دارفور كما اشار
مدير البرنامج الى اصابه طائره امميه
للخدمات الانسانيه في مطار الخرطوم باضرار
جسيمه وقد دانت الامم المتحده مقتل
موظفيها في السودان وعبر ممثلها الخاص
بولكرسيس عن انزعاجه الشديد من التقارير
التي افادت عن تعرض منشات الامم المتحده
ومباني انسانيه اخرى لاطلاق نار في دار
فرع وحث المسؤول الاممي جميع الاطراف على
احترام التزاماتها الدوليه بما في ذلك
كفاله سلامه وامن موظفي الامم المتحده
وجميع العاملين في المجال الانساني